[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález se
multiplican los esfuerzos diplomáticos
por parte de diferentes actores para
evitar una mayor escalada de tensión y
un conflicto a gran escala en territorio
ucraniano pese a las reuniones las
llamadas e intercambio de mensajes de
alto nivel rusia se mantiene en sus
reclamos sobre la expansión de la otan
hacia el este del continente y dio
inicio a ejercicios militares en
colaboración con belarús veamos la
siguiente gráfica para ponernos en
contexto estás ucrania que ya la tenemos
acá bien definida esta es la reconocida
ya región del donbass en donde ha habido
tensión a lo largo de los últimos años
las ciudades de lugansk con jets
mariupol en la costa la ciudad de harkov
desde donde precisamente france24 les ha
estado reportando al otro lado de la
frontera está rusia aquí es donde han
desplegado ya cientos de militares en
rusos a lo largo de las últimas semanas
pero también al norte de la ciudad de
kiev la capital ucraniana solamente 235
kilómetros de la capital de ese país en
la ciudad bielorrusa de minsk rusia y
belarús comenzó hacer ejercicios
militares en conjunto también al sur acá
en el mar negro y en el mar de azov aquí
en el mar negro hay tropas desplegadas
del ejército ruso que están en la base
de sebastopol estratégicamente puesta
aquí en la península de crimea y también
aquí hay presencia militar en el mar de
azov precisamente para garantizar el
suministro económico a la península de
crimea desde territorio ruso a través
del estrecho de kers como ustedes pueden
ver tanto el norte el este como el sur
de ucrania están prácticamente rodeadas
de todo planes que han sido desplegadas
por rusia pero también la otan y eeuu
han hecho lo suyo y no se han quedado
quietos y también han desplegado varias
tropas veamos entonces la siguiente
gráfica vemos como eeuu movilizó cerca
de 3.000 soldados a puntos estratégicos
en países como alemania en polonia y
también en rumanía que son países que
hacen parte de la otan el reino unido
por su parte hizo lo mismo y desplegó
soldados al norte en estonia que tiene
frontera terrestre con la federación de
rusia alemana también desplegó un
centenar de soldados aquí a lituania que
tiene frontera con belarús y frontera
con el enclave ruso de kaliningrado esto
es un territorio ruso que está separado
del territorio continental del país como
ustedes pueden ver los países que están
en azul son los países que forman la
otan son los países que hacen parte de
esa alianza militar del atlántico según
esto el mapa entonces que nos dice que
tenemos presencia la votan por el lado
del oeste belarús y ucrania en el norte
y en el este y también despliegue de las
tropas rusas en el sur de ucrania en las
costas del mar negro tanto el presidente
de francia emmanuel macrón como el
canciller de alemania olaf scholz
expresaron su preocupación por la
situación pero la misma unión europea le
está costando generar consenso sobre
este tema
y seguiremos actuando en las próximas
semanas como objetivos simples el
primero se ha dicho es evitar la guerra
y la pelea es la paz y la estabilidad
del continente europeo son nuestro
tesoro y consideramos que debemos hacer
todo para preservarlo
fayt una violación de la integridad
territorial y la soberanía de ucrania es
inaceptable y tendrá consecuencias de
gran alcance para rusia política
económica y ciertamente también
geoestratégicamente
del otro lado rusia afirma estar un poco
confundida con esta estrategia
diplomática de occidente con
advertencias despliegue de soldados
condiciones y esa falta de engranaje que
tal parece se está presentando entre
washington y bruselas algo que a rusia
parece convenirle escuchemos al
canciller ruso sérguei lávrov
los enfoques ideologizados de los
ultimátums y las amenazas nos llevan a
ninguna parte
desafortunadamente muchos de nuestros
colegas occidentales se dejan llevar por
esta forma de actividad pública y no
puedo llamar la diplomacia
bueno pues para analizar este tema
saludamos en la ciudad de buenos aires
en argentina a tamara yevtushenko ella
es doctora en ciencias políticas es
coordinadora de la cátedra de rúsia del
instituto de relaciones internacionales
de la universidad de la plata en
argentina también está con nosotros
nicolás depedro analista senior del
institute for stay craft en londres en
el reino unido pero se une a esta
conversación desde la ciudad de
barcelona en españa ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos sus comentarios
y sus preguntas las pueden hacer a
través de nuestras redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram y en
twitter estamos como france24 guión bajo
s arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 deje todos sus
preguntas y todos sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales ustedes
también hacen parte de este debate
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
de tamara allí en argentina y comienzo
por preguntarle tamara ha habido
múltiples acercamientos a nivel
diplomático pero tanto puede resistir la
diplomacia vista como la estamos viendo
desde occidente desde la perspectiva
rusia rusa también antes de que haya
algún movimiento algún detonante allí en
ucrania
si la situación es bastante compleja
pero hay que destacar que es un
conflicto antes que nada geopolítico no
es el conflicto territorial y también lo
que vemos un poco los medios de
comunicación demonizan rusia en este
momento como nunca y rusia- varias veces
denunció falsas acusaciones y ataques
del occidente y rusia en no hay ningún y
rusia no hay ningún movimiento
organizado contra la guerra eso hace
poco
destacó el investigador andrew calificó
del centro carnegie por eso yo creo que
diplomacia lo que tienen que
concentrarse en cumplir los pactos y los
acuerdos es lo que insiste rusia cumplir
el acuerdo de mins el acuerdo de ming
fue firmado en 2015 y esa es la idea
principal que
el otan la otan y también los estado
bueno se ha congelado ahí la señal de
skype con tamara en argentina continuó
con nicolás quien está también con
nosotros en la línea para debatir y
analizar este tema nicolás bienvenido al
programa como siempre un gusto
saludarlos y la misma pregunta que le
estaba haciendo a tamara como punto de
partida de este análisis y este debate
muchos acercamientos diplomáticos alto
nivel viajes entre
representantes de la unión europea de
diferentes países hacia rusia hacia
ucrania y viceversa que tanto va a poder
resistir la diplomacia esta atención que
se está viviendo en ucrania antes de que
haya un detonante
bueno esto es difícil de anticipar lo
que es seguro es que digamos la vía
diplomática está encontrando
dificultades fundamentalmente porque
rusia está haciendo unas exigencias de
máximos inaceptables tanto para ucrania
como para como para europa vía ucrania
básicamente le está exigiendo que acepte
una rendición incondicional y que
ucrania se convierta pues en una suerte
de
protectorado ruso gestionado desde moscú
y los ucranianos no están por la labor y
a los europeos y eeuu lo que le está
pidiendo básicamente es que se desarme y
se desmantele lo que ha sido el orden de
seguridad europeo en los últimos 30 a 40
años y sus principios fundamentales y
esto evidentemente no resulta aceptable
y ese es el punto muerto en el que
estamos en la digamos en las
negociaciones diplomáticas si habrá
guerra o no o un ataque a gran escala de
euro se controló cree en esto sólo puede
ser de rusia porque la única posibilidad
de que el único escenario en el que
puede haber un gran enfrentamiento
convencional es aquel en el que rusia
decide lanzar un ataque contra ucrania
no hay ningún otro no hay rusia no
afrontó una amenaza militar nadie es
amenazado usar la fuerza contra rusia
etcétera etcétera o sea que ese es el
único escenario y en consecuencia sólo
el presidente putin puede estar seguro
de si están dispuestos a llegar hasta el
punto de lanzar un ataque contra contra
ucrania
nicolás así como usted pone las cosas en
rusia es donde está el balón en este
momento en este en este tablero
diplomático y político de europa pero
rusia ha dicho en reiteradas ocasiones
que su interlocutor que no sabemos si se
refiere a estados unidos oa europa
porque maneja a los dos
interlocutores de manera distinta no los
oye y no presta atención a lo que ellos
piden como analiza usted estas
declaraciones por parte del gobierno
ruso
bueno rusia desde el primer momento dejó
muy claro que sólo estaba interesada en
tratar con eeuu que es el único al que
le reconoce de igual a igual y esto
persigue bueno varias cosas una es una
nostalgia de los tiempos de la guerra
fría en los que a un lado se sentaba
eeuu y al otro en la unión soviética y
también busca de forma implícita
dividir a los europeos y erosionar el
vínculo transatlántico esto es un
objetivo estratégico para rusia si
consigue erosionar tanto el vínculo
transatlántico que acabe quebrando esto
será una extras de interés prioritario
para para rusia y al mismo tiempo juega
la división de los europeos porque
evidentemente sabe que hay países
europeos más alineados más próximos más
sensibles
hacia washington y otros que están más
por bueno por aumentar esto que se llama
la autonomía o ahora en la brújula
estratégica de la unión europea y
entonces evidentemente rusia juega con
esas claves aquí es importante y es muy
evidente que rusia ha exigido un
impuesto que la unión europea como tal
no forme parte de las innovaciones que
no esté en la mesa
y está jugando y está apostando desde
hace meses y ahora lo ha hecho muy
explícito era era en mi opinión bastante
claro desde hace tiempo pero ahora lo ha
explicitado de forma muy clara que no
quiere reconocer a la unión europea como
un interlocutor político aunque no es un
actor con el que quiere tratar en clave
política sino que quiere tratar
individualmente con algunos países
europeos singularmente alemania y
también francia y algún otro no y llevar
a estas divisiones porque la más
dividida está europa más débil es menor
es la respuesta y más fuerte a rusia
proporcionalmente no en comparación con
los europeos claro que ahí es a donde
llega mi siguiente pregunta porque esta
semana veíamos a el presidente de rusia
vladimir putin reunido con el presidente
de francia manuel marco desde francia
haciendo gestiones en nombre de la unión
europea y tratando de apaciguar un poco
la atención y de entender que lo que
está buscando precisamente el kremlin
con toda esta atención y esta escala y
despliegue de militares en las fronteras
ucranianas allí entonces como entiende
uno putin con quien estaba conversando
con el presidente de francia o con un
representante de la unión europea
bueno claro eso genera digamos macros se
robó un papel como presente la unión
europea que como tal bueno en francia es
un país se clave muy importante entró en
europea pero se roba un papel que no le
corresponde y rusia explota esa cuestión
sabiendo que eso va a generar y
comprensión y malestar en otros estados
miembros de la unión europea no el ruso
también está explotando el hecho de que
francia está en campaña lector en
precampaña electoral ya en las
elecciones presidenciales son dentro de
poco y yo creo que la visita de macrón
también hay que entenderla en ese
sentido que está tratando bueno pues de
anular la posibilidad de que otros
actores políticos que se están
selecciones puedan emplear esta carta
contra contra macro no en clave de la
tradición colista en francia etcétera y
esto bueno es lo que la carta que
explota rusia tanto esta cuestión
electoral como el hecho de que genera
divisiones porque aquí el fracaso
digamos de los europeos ha sido no
imponer su propia voz y permitir que
haya este juego de este goteo de
diferentes representantes no y aído
también viktor orbán la semana que viene
va al canciller alemán
y bueno esto evidentemente debilita la
posición de la unión europea como tal
rusia lo está explotando y los estados
miembros cada uno por su propia agenda
de sus propios intereses y su propia
visión del asunto han caído en esta en
mi opinión trampa que está sirviendo
precisamente para eso para debilitar a
la unión europea como tal
me reservo alguna de las preguntas sobre
el análisis de la relación que está
teniendo washington y bruselas para
abordar este tema para analizarlas
también con tamara con quien estamos
intentando restablecer la conexión
nicolás pero mientras tanto quiero
conversar sobre otra pieza de este
rompecabezas
que ha entrado también a jugar pero no
sé desde su punto de vista usted qué tan
importante lo vea y es la presencia de
turquía que se ofreció a mediar una
oferta por parte de ankara un
ofrecimiento de mediación para reducir
estas tensiones el canciller turco
mevlüt
cavusoglu está tratando de acercarse
aquí
que tanto puede ayudar turquía en esta
mediación que papel estratégico está
jugando allí o que tanto está
aprovechando el gobierno turco toda esta
tensión en la región para apaciguar un
poco el malestar que también hay dentro
de las fronteras turcas
bueno yo creo que rusia y turquía tienen
una relación compleja en inglés se llama
florian y mi amigo enemigo al mismo
tiempo y esto se proyecta claramente en
toda la región del cáucaso sur y también
lo hemos visto en el escenario sirio
alcanzan acuerdos pero también hay
disparidad de intereses y divisiones y
esto bueno pues ahora es un episodio más
en el contexto ucraniano aquí es más un
salvavidas un nuevo otro potencial amigo
para para ucrania que es la parte débil
y quien afronta realmente una amenaza
existencial no es a quien está rodeada
en todas sus fronteras como estaba antes
describiendo en el mapa no toda la
frontera de ucraniano con rusia en la
parte de bielorrusia y ahora también
toda la zona del mar negro y el mar de
soft no sea que digamos ucrania ahora
mismo puede ser atacada potencialmente
prácticamente por cualquier frente
excepto las fronteras con polonia
hungría eslovaquia y rumanía y bueno
esto para lo creen es importante se ha
hablado mucho de la del acuerdo para
fabricar drones turcos que han sido muy
eficaces en la última guerra de nagorno
karabaj
en ucrania y esto a medio plazo puede
ser importante para el cráneo pero a
corto plazo no tanto ya no tiene ese
efecto inmediato en clave de disuasión
militar pero sí a medio y largo plazo
desde luego es un factor más de
irritación y clave del kremlin porque lo
que quiere rusia es bueno
un protectorado sobre ucrania y entonces
lo que está diciendo es que no haya
relación ni de los países otan ni ahora
tampoco turkish lar pero sin duda para
ankara debe ser preocupante ver este
despliegue de tropas en el mar negro
justo frente a sus costas en donde ahora
rusia también está haciendo ejercicios
militares hemos retomado la comunicación
con tamara quiero entonces preguntar la
tamara sobre las posiciones que se están
tomando en torno a este tema sobre a
esta escalada de tensión tamara
bienvenida nuevamente al programa
estamos discutiendo con nicolás y
analizando entender la posición de rusia
que es lo que está tratando de hacer con
toda esta escalada de tensión y sobre
todo el manejo que le está dando a sus
interlocutores a quienes ha señalado de
no entender los pedidos que está
haciendo el kremlin dice que no entiende
el manejo que le está dando eeuu y la
unión europea a este tema que busca
rusia cómo se relaciona con estos
interlocutores
antes que nada rusia pide es cumplir con
todos los acuerdos como le había
funcionado los acuerdos del inc
que se puede ser más del 2015 entre
rusia ucrania alemán y francia y lo más
importante para rusia que no haya
ninguna
ampliación de bloqueo tan porque esto
representa a mí la separación seguridad
de hecho que el blog otan
se amplía cuando ya
desaparición la amenaza no existe la
unión soviética
pero nosotros vemos que el out antes de
99 entraron nuevos países de europa
central
polonia república checa hungría en 2004
entraron rumanía bulgaria países
bálticos y ahora intento proseguir con
georgia
hay que destacar que francia también ha
mantenido una postura más diplomática y
menos confrontativa con rusia
reconociendo las preocupaciones de
seguridad
de aceleración rusa
pero ahora ucrania
por eso ahora en el tema de ucrania
viene más de un conflicto de territorio
como había mencionado esto es un
conflicto geopolítico y lamentablemente
para los muchos la última encuesta
del pueblo ruso hacen expresa el
tremendo dolor por lo que está pasando
realizar la guerra
esta sin posible como anticipar la
guerra contra los mismos rusos porque
cada familia tiene cada segunda familia
tienen familiares en encontrar ya son
dos el eslavo que tienen
profunda hermandad la unidad espiritual
de los pueblos hermanos cultural ya no
se
anuncia cámara bien claro declaró que en
ningún momento va a empezar la guerra
pero tienen que respetar en la
accesibilidad
en los territorios de la generación rusa
clara obvia tamara muy puntual por favor
porque moscú insiste en tener el diálogo
directo con washington y dejar de lado a
la unión europea especificando un poco
más la pregunta que le estaba haciendo
al principio para tener ya punto de
partida en el debate
puede hacer por favor la pregunta de
vuelta no sé por qué insiste en tener
mayor comunicación con washington con
eeuu que con la unión europea
consideró que con washington son las
reacciones más complicados washington ha
rechazado las demandas
rusas la promesa de bloquear el ingreso
de un tram en la otan y frenar la
expansión de la alianza militar hacia el
este con europa tenemos más
entendimiento
con la unión europea tenemos varios
proyectos también en washington puedes
bloquear el north stream el gasoducto
un proyecto enorme a través del cual si
puede tener con alemania y pueden tener
un ir a europa
y hacer dos aliados entre europa y rusia
si considero que esto puede perjudicar
más que nada en la relación entre europa
y rusia
la intervención de obama y
si debo avanzar con otros temas de la
agenda le pido por favor sea más puntual
con las respuestas por favor para
abordar más más temas quiero preguntarle
a nicolás ahora sobre esas declaraciones
del primer ministro de polonia matheus
moravia aquí quien dice en algunas
declaraciones que el objetivo político
de putin es simplemente dividir la otan
a como de lugar que piensa usted de
estas declaraciones nicolás
sé que reflejan la realidad claro el
objetivo es erosionar el vínculo
transatlántico su manifestación más
tangible es la otan y generar todas
estas divisiones dentro de la otan es es
un objetivo de interés prioritario para
para rusia cuanto mayor es la unidad
entre los europeos sea en el marco de la
otan o sea en el marco de la unión
europea mayores dificultades tiene rusia
para imponer su agenda o para que sus
digamos movimientos agresivos y
amenazantes surtan efecto así que busca
evidentemente el divide y vencerás y
tamara su opinión dividir la otan es uno
de los de las misiones que tiene moscú
como lo vio usted
para una cuchilla pregunta disculpe le
preguntaba que su opinión sobre este
comentario del primer ministro de
polonia de que moscú tiene como cometido
dividir la otan
yo creo que sí
presidente putin
expresó bien claro aunque
en su declaración qué
si ucrania entre la otan intenta
recuperar crimea en este caso es lo que
puede dañar la
la integridad rusa por eso considero que
de ningún modo es la táctica y la
estrategia de la federación rusa es
dividir otan de hecho que la otan es el
bloque más potente en este momento pero
el círculo de los países que se acercan
al territorio ruso para rearmar en cerca
de nuestro territorio y es
inevitable el conflicto
que puede sí que tiene que se tiene que
solucionar pero de modo pacífico
obviamente a base
a base de los acuerdos y
en
1997 que fue también
una acta muy importante que
se extiende mucho está en sus respuestas
lamento tenerla que corta pero es que
tengo muchos temas y se me acaba el
programa nicolás y quiero analizar con
usted una de las propuestas que hay
sobre la mesa que es declarar a ucrania
como un territorio neutral como es
finlandia y como es suecia es esto
viable que necesitaría ucrania para
poderlo lograr y cómo sería visto esto
desde moscú porque claramente todos los
movimientos que da ucrania son evaluados
desde el kremlin
bueno muy rápido en primer lugar
evidentemente esto lo tienen que decir
los ucranianos hay que recordar que
queremos un país independiente y
soberano en consecuencia son sus
ciudadanos y su gobierno legítimo el que
tiene que tomar estas decisiones dicho
esto la finalización que es el término
que está utilizando el kremlin y por
finlandia entendemos a finalización la
finlandia de hoy día es decir un país
democrático e integrado en la unión
europea y con una cooperación en materia
de seguridad defensa fluida con la otan
evidentemente esto sería un escenario
deseado por probablemente por los
ucranianos y razonable y bueno para su
prosperidad pero por finalización el
kremlin básicamente entiende un
protectorado sobre el que tiene
capacidad de injerencia y de imponer su
voluntad sobre el gobierno de kiev es
decir reducir la soberanía y la
independencia de ucrania y por eso
ucraniano está aceptando estos estos
términos y estas exigencias nicolás
continuó con usted porque mantenemos
intentando aquí restablecer la conexión
con tamara seguimos teniendo problemas
le pregunto ahora también por una
declaración que ha hecho la otan que
apunta
contempla la posibilidad de tener
presencia permanente de tropas en los
estados bálticos esto no generará aún
más tensión con rusia lo pregunto porque
uno de estos países por ejemplo estonia
tiene frontera con rusia esto no sería
ponerle un poco más de leña al fuego que
ya está ardiendo allí en el este
bueno la presencia de tropas de otan en
países limítrofes con rusia es son pocos
pero tienen son muy son muy escasas
todavía hasta ahora son tropas de
carácter rotatorio es decir van rotando
no hay presencia permanente es muy
pequeña la salvedad lo que tiene es que
son tropas siempre de destacamentos o
despliegues de carácter multinacional es
una muestra de solidaridad y lo que se
busca es precisamente generar disuasión
no hay ninguna voluntad ofensiva hacia
rusia no hay ningún intento de usar la
fuerza la amenaza de la fuerza el único
mensaje que se le está lanzando a rusia
es de intentar la disuadir precisamente
de elevar la tensión y optar por bueno
pues buscar un aumento de la tensión
militar o de la confrontación no digamos
la confrontación y esta es la cuestión o
sea que es básicamente un mensaje de
solidaridad entre los aliados y de
tratar de disuadir a rusia porque es que
recuerdo insisto claro no hay ninguna
otra posibilidad de que haya guerra en
europa que esa porque nadie está
pensando y nadie tiene la más remota
idea de utilizar la fuerza o atacar
nicolás usted habla de aliados vemos a
todo el bloque de la otan la comunidad
internacional preocupada por esta
situación vemos a rusia que es la que
tiene prácticamente el balón en su lado
de la cancha en cuanto a la toma de
decisiones pero rusia con quien se está
articulando vemos belarús que es un país
con el que está haciendo ejercicios
militares pero que más apoyo puede tener
rusia en la agenda internacional
bueno belarús más que un apoyo es lo que
sea que sea ucraniano un vasallo que
básicamente la tiene que aceptar
su condición subordinada sobre moscú
pero bueno el otro país o el otro gran
baluarte que tiene rusia en este momento
evidentemente china
no es exactamente una alianza pero hay
claramente una convergencia estratégica
creciente entre uno y otro y ahí esto le
permite a rusia afrontar la posibilidad
de que haya sanciones o digamos
tensiones diplomáticas con mucha mayor
tranquilidad en la medida en que sabe
que va a contar con el respaldo
activo de china sin que china vaya
involucrarse en esto porque china
también tiene en sus intereses
económicos con los socios europeos con
sus socios europeos son mayores que los
que tiene con rusia pero en este plano
estratégico claramente va a haber está
ahí está bueno suma de fuerzas como poco
no porque además a china también le
interesa no en la medida en que bueno
pues se distrae la atención de eeuu se
debilita la idea de que hay un bloque
euro atlántico muy fuerte esto hace que
la proyección de eeuu social
indo-pacífico sea menos bueno tenga
mayores dificultades se produce con
menos fuerza aquí me resulta interesante
nicolás a analizar con usted un consenso
básico que hay al interior de la otan y
es que no pueden aceptar la
incorporación de un país nuevo dentro de
la alianza si este país ya está bajo una
situación de conflicto esto también
puede ser un as bajo la manga para el
kremlin para garantizar que ucrania no
se acerque más a la otan o que
definitivamente entre en esta alianza
sea mejor al kremlin fomentarla el
inicio allí de un conflicto dentro de
las fronteras ucranianas este puede ser
entonces un argumento para para el
kremlin y queda un poco ya garantizado
ahí el inicio de un conflicto como lo ve
usted
si efectivamente el hecho de que se haya
provocara e insertará en mi opinión
artificialmente un conflicto en el este
de ucrania en la primavera de 2014
perseguía efectivamente ese objetivo
mientras haya un conflicto armado y haya
una disputa territorial dentro del país
el país queda muy bloqueado en su acción
exterior y no digamos pues por eso no te
es no va a entrar ni en european y no
está aquí conviene recordar que ni en
2014 ni tampoco ahora había ningún plan
a medio plazo en el horizonte inmediato
el horizonte previsible en el que
ucrania ingrese en la alianza atlántica
así que esta crisis tiene por eso
digamos ese carácter artificial generada
ahora por el kremlin o desde desde
noviembre del año pasado que empezaron a
amasar tropas en la frontera porque no
hay ningún plan para que ucrania
ingresará en la otan lo que no quiere
hacer otan y eeuu es hacer una renuncia
explícita y es escrita en papel y que
sea jurídicamente vinculante renunciando
a principios fundamentales
y uno de ellos es que los países son hay
que respetar su integridad territorial y
su soberanía y un acto soberano de un
estado es decidir en bueno a qué club se
quiere adherirse y la otan es un club
abierto en el que luego sus miembros
pueden decidir deciden obviamente si
quieren admitir a un miembro o no pero
no pueden vetar a alguien si es un
estado democrático europeo porque lo
imponga un tercero en este caso rusia
otorgando un derecho de veto esto es lo
que no se quiere conceder nicolás pero
usted le parece esa una garantía viable
para que rusia contemple la posibilidad
de descargar esta atención qué garantías
necesita el kremlin para contemplar
empezar a bajar un poco las aguas
bueno esta es una pregunta muy difícil
porque rusia ha hecho estas exigencias
de máximos y la respuesta que ha
recibido por parte de eeuu sí otan que
tienen matices en cada uno de los
documentos que se han conocido de la
filtración que se publicó hace unos días
pero básicamente lo que le están
diciendo es que no os discutirán que los
principios fundamentales no están en
cuestión lo cual es una buena noticia
para los europeos pero le dan a moscú le
ofrecen toda una panoplia de
posibilidades para abordar temas que
tienen que ver con la transparencia
militar la creación de confianza y el
control de armamentos si moscú realmente
percibirá una amenaza en clave militar y
tuviera una ansiedad en ese sentido
esta oferta sería atractiva para rusia
pero no se ha dicho que no que estos son
sólo temas secundarios que nos aborde
los temas importantes y que es
insuficiente e insatisfactoria hasta
esta respuesta eso bueno unido al hecho
de que los ucranianos no dan ninguna
muestra en ningún índice ninguna señal
de que estén por rendirse y por
claudicar y aceptar el protectorado y la
tutela que exige moscú que además está
exigiendo que haya prácticamente una
reducción al máximo de la relación que
mantiene que con una serie de países a
que apenas haya cooperación tanto en
ámbitos políticos como militares pues
deja la situación francamente muy
difícil atisbar que cuál va a ser el
próximo paso de russian principios y si
puede haber una guerra o no esto sólo
está en manos lo saben de la decisión
que tome definitivamente rusia
hemos hablado de rusia hemos hablado de
la otan de la unión europea de eeuu nos
falta hablar para el cierre del programa
para estos pocos minutos que nos queda
de ucrania que salidas tiene este país
para evitar la confrontación para evitar
perder su soberanía y que moscú entienda
que es un país independiente que toma
sus propias decisiones pero que tampoco
puede ser completamente dependiente de
otan o de países cercanos de la unión
europea o de eeuu para defenderse y
poder
reaccionar ante los movimientos rusos
bueno ucrania hecho dos cosas una por un
lado e intentar dar muestras de la
solidez y su determinación para resistir
y esto genera o puede generar ya veremos
un efecto disuasorio en rusia la
desproporción de fuerzas es muy grande
todavía a rusia la fuerza que ha amasado
es muy superior a la que puede
contraponer ucrania pero bueno un gran
está mostrando su voluntad de resistir y
esto evidentemente en el cálculo del
kremlin porque puede generarle costes
evidentemente a rusia no y por otro lado
aquí el el problema es que la otra
interviniente hablaba hacía referencia
al protocolo de bits que han firmado
firman en 2015 no el problema es que hay
dos interpretaciones del ínter del
protocolo de minsk line el texto es
bueno es suficientemente al mismo como
para que se pudiera afirmar pero rusia
lo que entiende es que hay que otorgarle
el derecho de veto a las regiones del
donbass sobre la política de kiev y
quien no acepta esa interpretación lo
que dice es que puede aceptar una
descentralización política y
administrativa pero no concederle
derecho de veto en manos de un terrario
y entonces seguimos en ese digamos
apoyado y diplomático no nicolás pues le
agradezco haber hecho este análisis para
la audiencia de france 24 aquí en
américa latina' yo les pido disculpas
por los inconvenientes técnicos que
tuvimos en el programa de hoy que nos
impidió tener en una conexión en óptimas
condiciones con tamara yevtushenko en la
ciudad de buenos aires- que era la
contraparte de este debate para conocer
la perspectiva rusa y ucraniana y nos
queda un poco cojo el programa les pido
disculpas por eso pero la tecnología no
jugó de nuestro lado en esta oportunidad
pero ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
preguntas y comentarios a través de las
redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]